The grammar of graphics is a formalism surrounding the principles of
creating visualizations.
Leland Wilkinson invented the theory in his seminal book,
the Grammar of Graphics in 1999.
To make reasoning and thinking about graphics and charts easier.
You might be asking yourself, what exactly do you mean,
when you say the grammar of of graphics is a visualization theory?
I thought visualizations had to be physical, with lines,
circles, axis, and represents some underlying data.
Well, Leland Wilkinson invented this theory in his seminal book titled by
the same name to make reasoning and thinking about graphics easier.
Think of it as defining a set of best practices for
developing and iterating on a data visualization.
At its most fundamental level,
the grammar of graphics makes a distinction to separate content from aesthetic.
Or in our case our data from our visual presentation of it.
Now this may not seem like a groundbreaking theory but before the grammar of
graphics researchers, artists, and developers often coupled the information they
were trying to communicate very tightly with their medium of communication.